just going to bring you a reminder of
the news that we broke you just before
we go uh his majesty the king's State
visit to France which was of course
going to be the first of his Reign has
been postponed that is uh news that
we've received from the Elysee Palace
the French presidency has said that uh
that is due to the protests that have
been taking place in the country over
the retirement age reforms uh we've just
heard from the prime minister's office
here uh he's just said King Charles is
uh French uh postponement of his visit
was taken with the consent of all
parties and that was after the president
of France asked the British government
to postpone the visit obviously uh
Jean-Luc malachon who's a prominent
left-wing uh politician and a former
French presidential candidate in fact he
actually said yesterday that he would
advise the king not to visit France he
was due to be visiting the Palace of
Versailles